alors que le déconfinement et amorcer
les gilets jaunes ont donc lancé les
appels on vient d'en parler à manifester
pour le samedi 16 mai à toulouse à
montpellier également ou encore à alès
dans le gard si la crainte de voir le
communisme se propager prévaut chez
certains d'autres souhaitent à nouveau
battre le pavé et dénoncer la gestion
sanitaire de la crise des autorités les
gilets jaunes peuvent ils revenir c'est
l'objet de notre face à face ce soir et
pour en débattre nous sommes avec jérôme
rodriguez gilet jaune à ses côtés
benjamin cauchy anciens au gilet jaune
actuellement en porte parole de debout
la france bonsoir à tous les deux merci
dany en direct avec nous sur rt france
jérôme rodriguez première question pour
vous on voit un retour de ces gilet
jaune sur le terrain à peine le
déconfinement commence pourquoi se faire
réentendre maintenant est ce que pour
vous c'était le moment idéal c'est la
chose la plus drôle qu'on entend depuis
maintenant un an et demi c'est là le
même champ lexical du léger légion de
s'essouffler gilet jaune reviennent mais
on n'est pas partis les jets les jeunes
étaient bien que les enfants il était
enfermé chez soi et compris vous faire
bien sûr moi le premier bien entendu
mais rien nous a empêchés d'être actif
sur différents réseaux sociaux et de
pouvoir se faire entendre malgré tout et
malgré là la puissance médiatique faite
sur le virus
on a été bien présent pendant les deux
mois donc les termes revenir non on
revient dans la rue parce que
aujourd'hui la colère peut-être des
confiné benjamin kusi pour vous le
moment est opportun les gilet jaune
alors on va faire attention à la
sémantique mais en france et tous ont
pris voilà qui reviennent en tout cas
devant la scène qui manifestent au
premier jour de ce déconfinement c'est
le moment opportun pour vous je prône
depuis 18 mois et jérôme l'a très bien
résumé les gie les jeunes se sont jamais
arrêtés et vous pouvez enfermé un homme
comme nelson mandela pendant 25 ans dans
une prison
devrait empêcher d'avoir un discours de
vérité donc ce n'est certainement pas en
enfermant sort de liberté conditionnelle
qui était ce confinement des centaines
de milliers d'opposants à emmanuel
macron que les gie les jeunes avaient
disparu le mouvement des gilets jaunes
pour moi aujourd'hui n'était que le
premier étage d'une fusée d'une
contestation de beaucoup plus large
c'est pour ça que le trj les jeunes il
est pratique pour les médias parce que
c'est identifie les pratiques pour le
gouvernement parce que ça permet de
salir l'opposition au gouvernement mac
rognan mais rassurez-vous des citoyens
en colère des citoyens tout simplement
qu'ils ont un cerveau vous assurer qu'il
y en a à peu près 68 millions sur 75
millions de français continuent à
réfléchir et continue à agir est-ce
qu'il était opportun d'agir dès le
premier jour moi je ne suis pas
convaincu qu'il faille retourner dans la
rue je le dis depuis des mois pour
combattre
emmanuel macron il y à bien d'autres
solutions jérôme rodriguez s'est pas
vous faire réagir sur ce qu'a dit
benjamin cauchy parce que je crois que
vous n'avez pas entendu j'espère que de
travailler pardonnez-nous alors je vais
essayer de faire l'interview croisée à
défaut d'un débat pour le moment puisque
voilà on y travaille de façon à ce que
vous puissiez vous entendre mutuellement
vous diriez vous que vous êtes plutôt
plus en colère qu'avant cette cette
crise - en colère ou a finalement c'est
pareil ça n'a rien changé est-ce qu'il
ya quelque chose que vous reprochez en
particulier au gouvernement dans la
gestion de cette liste qui a renforcé
votre colère non la colère reste la même
parce que au final le virus n'a fait que
démontrer à ceux à qui on essaye
d'éveiller les consciences depuis
bientôt deux ans mettre en avant les les
défaillances de ce gouvernement
maintenant en termes de responsabilité
la seule responsabilité aujourd'hui je
vais incomber à macron c'est celle de
nous avoir menti parce qu'il était au
courant depuis longtemps au sujet des
masques et qui nous a clairement menti
ce gouvernement a clairement menti au
peuple français
je ne peux pas lui laisser la
responsabilité totale et entière de ce
qui se passe aujourd'hui dans les autres
taux de croissance que ça fait vingt ans
que ça dure cent mille lits en moins 22
millions de personnes en plus
aujourd'hui aux urgences par rapport il
ya un pas en arrière
donc la responsabilité en incombe à
l'ensemble des gouvernements aussi bien
sarkozy hollande et makro maintenant ce
qui est désolant de voir chez makro et
les principaux titulaires de l air eau m
c'est de venir se plaindre que ce ne
sont pas à eux de porter cette
responsabilité
à eux de ne pas se présenter à des
élections s'ils ne veulent pas route ne
pas prendre la responsabilité de ce qui
a pu faire auparavant
les anciens gouvernements et je tiens à
rappeler comme accro faisait partie du
gouvernement d'hollande
force est de constater qu'il était au
courant pendant la l'élection
présidentielle de la part de monsieur
salomon que si un jour il y aurait
pandémie en france on serait dans une
sacrée panade
force est de constater qu'en décembre il
était au courant via le ministère de la
santé via les les propos qu'a pu tenir
l'ancien ministre de la santé inquiète
on ou de pourquoi on nous a menti du
jour au lendemain les masques ne sont
pas utiles et aujourd'hui les masques
sont devenus obligatoires voire même ont
subi une répression parce que pas de
masse 135 euros
voilà où on en est aujourd'hui et
aujourd'hui la colère reste la même
parce que personnellement ce virus alors
je vais peut-être être paradoxal n'a
fait pour moi apporter quelques points
positifs c'est d'ouvrir les yeux à
beaucoup de français parce que à défaut
d'applaudir sur leur balcon je tiens à
rappeler que ceux qui applaudissaient
sur leur balcon était assise sur les
terrasses de café à voir les
manifestants manifester et rigoler voir
se plaindre des manifestantes
ces manifestants ces soignants sont ceux
qui ont sauvé des vies hier et ceux à
qui on rigolait hier aussi
enfin qui ont sauvé des vies aujourd'hui
et qu'on rigolait sur leur territoire
benjamin cauchy je crois que la liaison
et est revenu votre réaction
vous êtes d'accord avec jérôme rodriguez
absolument je suis absolument d'accord
avec avec jérôme régit les jeunes que
tout le monde de décrier sont ce qu'on
appelle aujourd'hui les premiers de
cordée
et quand on est petit artisan quand on
est joueur et quand on est infirmière et
qu'on se faisait taper dessus
régulièrement tous les samedis et qu'on
demande sous forme de campus avec un
goût de marketing qui est à vomir
rendez-vous à 19h58 taper sur vos
casseroles mais j'ai envie de dire comme
le disait gerome plus de cent mille lits
sarko
si hollande tous ceux qui se sont
succédé et bien se tiennent aujourd'hui
par le parlement pour rester poli et
c'est pour ça qu'on voit qu'il ya une
opposition qui est extrêmement faible
donc il est important pour cela que les
revendications originel d'aidé gilet
jaune reviennent sur la table
je ne partage pas les mêmes méthodes
avec jérôme gestion de ces anciens qui
légende est ce que vous estimez toujours
que vous faites partir plus loin de ce
mouvement
en tout cas je le considère toujours
comme un citoyen qui ne supportent pas
qu'ils ne supportent pas ces
gouvernements successifs qui opprime le
peuple maintenant au delà des
référendums d'initiative citoyens qui
est un point de convergence porsche et
le citoyen en colère de novembre 2018
pour ma part je prône aussi une
démocratie représentative et si des
amendements n'avait pas été posée à
l'assemblée nationale la semaine
dernière pour éviter qu'une amnistie
soit mise en place pour que nos
gouvernants se protège parce que
justement comme l'a dit jérôme les
ministres macron et compagnie ont menti
ils voulaient passe en catimini dans
leur projet de loi une amnistie pour
être exemple de tout procès judiciaire
les bières si elle veut une opposition
parlementaire on n'aurait pas réussi
s'il n'y avait pas le conseil
constitutionnel qui avait censuré une
partie du tracking
tu as voulu être imposées par emmanuel
macron et ses amis eh bien ça ne
fonctionnerait pas donc oui je me sens
toujours gilet jaune mais avant tout je
me sens un citoyen qu'on a vraiment eu
ras la casquette de ne trouver de
solution à la contestation emmanuel
macron par deux mois jérôme que de
manifester il ya deux solutions il faut
fini jérôme r que je laisse la parole
si tous les gilets jaunes étaient allés
voter par exemple mais il reste un
deuxième tour des municipales dans
quasiment 5000 communes
bon tu sais très bien que je suis porte
parole aux ordres d'un parti politique
mais je veux pas parler de sept partis
politiques en parler de manière générale
voté contre tous ceux qui sont de près
ou de loin lié à emmanuel macron pour lé
second tour des prochaines élections
municipales
c'est une arme pacifique qui est dir est
probable sur les raisons
je te rejoins rejetant la joie il
moustiques dans la nature on est
irréprochable
benjamin roze connais tu es le premier
gilet jaune avec qui j'ai discuté je
tiens à rappeler j'ai pris un chemin
différent je ne suis parti pris de ne
jamais juger quelles sont les chemins
que les uns et les autres peuvent
prendre tu as décidé de prendre le
chemin de la politique
pensant que tu pouvais arranger les
choses sur ce terrain-là grand bien te
fasse force est de constater qu'il est
très compliqué d'avoir une union
nationale ne serait ce qu'à l'échelle
politique autant qu'il est difficile
d'avoir une union nationale à l'échelle
de l'ensemble des mouvements
contestataires et de citoyens en colère
qu'il soit jaune rouge ou autre couleur
ce que je veux dire à la wii
les manifestations ça reste important
parce que ça reste visible ça reste
ancrée dans l'histoire de france que de
sortir dans la rue et de montrer notre
mécontentement le plus pacifiquement
possible sans subir la répression
gouvernementale
mais d'autres actions sont en cours
beaucoup plus ciblées comme on a pu voir
les constituants aujourd'hui investir un
ministère et pouvoir avoir accès à un
rendez vous ça fait aussi partie des
actions d'autres actions sont menées
aussi bien sur les réseaux sociaux
il n'y a pas eu que il n'y a pas eu que
toulouse il ya eu en g aujourd'hui
devant un hôpital il ya eu il ya eu
valenciennes devant un hôpital
il ya eu bandol bossi qui a manifesté il
ya plein d'action toutes les actions
aujourd'hui qui permettront de mettre en
avant l'ensemble de nos revendications
qui restent les mêmes de base et mettre
à défaut l'ensemble des actions du
gouvernement sont les bienvenus et
aujourd'hui un gilet jaune ne se doit
pas de juger ce que fait la ou l'autre
c'est de prendre de la responsabilité d'
adhérer à un projet ou ne pas attirer un
projet mois les manifestations les
appels à la manifestation ne serait ce
que 5 dit y arrive
j'en appelle à la responsabilité de ceux
qui appellent au vu de ce qui se passait
il ya deux mois en arrière la répression
subie
sachez qu'aujourd'hui on va prendre
double dose mais si on apprendre double
tour de parler sa liberté sont mis en
place
donc oui on est d'accord j'appelle moi
aussi au vote j'appelle à tous ceux qui
croient en la force des urnes a voté
contre macron d'accord ne serait ce que
pour le punir d'avoir validé des
élections de premier tour qui n'ont fait
que faire progresser le virus j'appelle
ça de la mise en danger de la vie
d'autrui et ils doivent ils se doivent
d'en porter la responsabilité parce
qu'aujourd'hui il ya des gens qui ont
perdu des êtres chers messieurs
restait 55 jours ont fini par donner
marché j'ai une question à vous poser un
salarié sur deux était au chômage
partiel pris en charge par l'état alors
évidemment il ya des gens qui ont perdu
leur travail leur travail des
intermittents des pigistes
voilà des des intérimaires il y en a
énormément
il n'empêche l'état a répondu présent
pour la plupart est ce que c'est quelque
chose quand même que vous êtes météo ça
n'a pas suffi selon vous va jamin cauchy
et goûter l'état a rendu au peuple
l'argent que le peuple le lui donne par
le biais des impôts par le biais des
taxes
le fait que l'on un état le fait que
l'on un état stratège
nous ça nous dérange pas nous ce qui
nous dérange c'est que comme le dirait
michel onfray c'est que nous ne
subissons un état maastricht rien et que
c'est l'union européenne qui décide et
par exemple bien bien y soit qu'il y ait
14 3 millions de personnes en chômage
partiel qui ait pu avoir ce filet de
sécurité
mais aujourd'hui on est obligé d'aller
quémander à des banques prises et de
l'argent pour pouvoir relancer pays
puisque la banque centrale européenne
refusent de prêter directement aux états
donc il va falloir que nous retrouvions
notre souveraineté monétaire
donc ne nous cachons pas derrière
l'arbre bravo l'état a donné 14 à aider
14 à 8 3 millions de français avec le
chômage partiel
non non non on les français ont récupéré
l'argent pour lesquels ils cotisent
maintenant c'est un arbre la forêt c'est
là les banques centrales doivent servir
directement aux états pour notamment
reconstruire des services publics de
qualité un hôpital de qualité une
justice de qualité libérer les
territoires abandonnés que sont les
banlieues ras le bol qui est des gamins
qui crèvent pied des cages d'escaliers
ras-le-bol qui est des paysans à 500
balles ras-le-bol qui aidé des
handicapés en fauteuil roulant gérone tu
te souviens qu'ils gagnent 500 balles et
qui tous les samedis tourner en rond
autour d'un rond point
mais quel malheur que de voir ça quelle
beauté de les voir sortir tous les
samedis mais quelle honte d'être la
septième puissance mondiale et de voir
des gens obligés de faire l'aumône
alors non arrêtons temps là bravo l'état
pour les 14
millions de chômeurs percée l'aider on
peut s'en féliciter
mais ce n'est qu'un arbre qui cache la
forêt où aujourd'hui c'est le monde de
la finance qui est en train de nous
bouffer et ça je pense qu avec jérôme on
est d'accord
jérôme rodriguez le mot de la fin s'il
vous plaît
pour compléter ce que dit benjamin je
tiens à rappeler à l'ensemble des
contribuables français que l'état n'est
pas une personne l'état n'a pas de poche
il n'a surtout pas les poches bien
remplies l'état sommes nous-mêmes moi
vous benjamin et tout ce qui peut vous
regardez et tous ceux qui ne regardent
pas donc sachez que cet argent à un
moment donné va falloir aller le
récupérer dans certaines poches
sachez que les poches ce ne sont pas les
nôtres elles sont déjà suffisamment
assez vide les vrais poche elles sont
celles par exemple chez carrefour qui
aujourd'hui progresse de 6% à la bourse
ou d'aller chercher l'argent à tous ceux
qui vont recevoir des dividendes sur la
belle année qu'ils ont pu passer l'année
d'avant voilà c'est là où l'argent faut
aller le chercher aujourd'hui et non pas
dans les poches de ceux qui hier mettait
à bas la france et qu'ils ont tenu à
bout de bras pendant deux mois
si beaucoup jérôme rodriguez benjamin
cochet d'avoir été avec nous en direct
sur rtl france merci à vous deux